there's a question about how it's how
it's come to the this realization
okay so funny sometimes it's like how
many times does this have to be said
there is no
realization okay there's only what
already was the baby when it was
apparently born is no different than the
dog or the cat it's innocent it doesn't
have any ideas it's already non-local it
doesn't even have a name okay it doesn't
have time the baby itself doesn't have
time okay all of that is just
added on ideas that then contract the
body into an entity into a time into a
location into separation into mutually
assur destruction into lack into all of
that fabricated it's just an
illusion It's Just an Illusion it's a
dream that's what it is
okay so it's not a realization it's not
a realization it's what already is it
it's already here here it is already